[Music]
hey what's up gq
it's polo g and these are my essentials
this right here is my jewelry set
i got all a necklace that go with this
jewelry set
uh this is one of my favorite ones i um
put together during
my album release of die legend and i got
inside of um like i got the picture
inside of the bezel of my watch the
picture of my album
my album cover and then i got it inside
of my chain like a
it's called a memory piece but i put
this whole set together during the
release of my album died legend
so this one of my favorite ones because
i transitioned from
yellow gold to rose gold my
i really like these pieces of gear my
album cover
got a lot of significance behind it
other than music because it got
all of my loved ones who passed away uh
on the cover so
i end up turning into something that i
could keep with me all the time
i never really clean my jury like that
unless i stop at
stop in the store and um they clean it
for me
i gotta learn how to now during this
quarantine
make sure my stuff's shining right this
is called like a gucci link
or a chain this bell this um
piece actually came with this chain and
all together it was like forty thousand
dollars
i got it from jury unlimited waffy
in atlanta one of my uh friends put me
up on to him
he was telling me like because i always
uh shop with a jeweler in chicago
named treasures and um he was telling me
like uh this guy he works with a lot of
artists within the industry
bailey like atlanta artists like little
baby uh the whole qc count
so i'm like yeah i'll probably start
shopping with him yeah i wear when i do
shows that's like a significant piece
let people know who i am uh this is a
patek philippe
this is uh about 115
000 this was like one of those watches
that i feel like
i made it like if i was to get one of
these so
it was always one of my plans to like
get one of these watches
we got the rocks on me for another
essential
i'm always got to have a decent amount
of money on me
i'm kind of overdoing it for this uh
interview i actually probably have had
like 30
000 but yeah i always just have some
carrying around money or
something that i can just go shopping
with in case my car lock up
cause i'm with bank of america so my car
always lock up
this is about 20 40.
60 okay i got my gucci book bag i just
got this all-star weekend
i was feeling like i really needed one
of these
traveling bags because i had like one of
these uh
like a regular book bag that i got from
like um spray ground and i was
carrying that around for like a year
until i got this bag just recently
i always need to keep this on i usually
keep like my jewelry
uh extra pack of underwear extra pack of
white t-shirts
my soul lotion stuff like that so when i
travel
i can get back ready and shoot out the
dope for my flight
another essential piece for me is like i
call it like a pouch
messenger bag type thing am i always hot
i just told me to go like i keep my
money in here
my wallet because i always lose stuff
until i just recently got a wallet not
too long ago
i remember last year i ran through about
eight uh state ids
i needed to get about eight state ids
last year so
i always keep this to keep my wallet
inside and
basically keep up with all my stuff this
uh
this is uh louis i think this was around
two thousand dollars
this is um my playstation playstation 4.
i just switched over from xbox to
playstation 4 last year
the xbox server was one really that good
i was fed up
i'm like man i'm switching over i don't
have enough
if i land in a city where i'm doing a
show at like
10 in the morning and i don't perform to
like 10 at night
i need something to just pass my time i
usually play 2k
i've been back up on gta real heavy
i play call of duty every year and again
i never really got into fortnite but i
want to start
trying it this is um
equate um eczema cream i got like
bad skin condition this is um dove
sensitive skin
so it's like non-scented that soap i
need a specific soap to wash up with or
my skin can
have a breakout and i always got to put
this lotion on
when i uh get out the shower or my skin
could uh have a breakout
i try everything else you saran
everything else that you could imagine
and these was the best things that
worked for me
these is my on my headphones i lost my
beats
so i gotta work with these i always keep
um a pair of headphones on me like just
to get through my
flights through my flights i always got
to listen to music i spend most of my
flight time listening to unreleased
music
like really getting the feel for it
listening to some of my favorite music
out there about certain artists that i
rock with but i always gotta have a
handful
yeah i'm not really a fan of airpods
because i always lose them
so i don't spend 200 on headphones just
to lose them or forget that in my ear
one fell out one still there i'm losing
my mind looking for the other one
i'm like really like really unorganized
most of the time so um
another thing i got is my passport i
always gotta have my passport
over my regular state id or license i
always keep it with me
as a former identification my passport
picture cool i don't really smile like
that so all my pictures look the same
if you can see a pretty clear picture it
looked kind of distorted though like an
android picture almost
i think uh last place i went was canada
i went to canada
for a show um i had like three shows out
there for a weekend
uh this is a mass right now that's a
very essential during this epidemic so
got to keep a mask on me whenever i'm
shooting out the door
make sure i grab a mask and some gloves
this is like um
a louis like a louis mass they made it
out of like scarves
out of out of a bunch of louis scarves i
got this from exclusive game
he does a lot of customs for like uh
other
famous rappers or artists in general
i got my my ocean spray
crayon grape it's the best juice in the
whole world
straight drop nothing better than this i
always need this in a studio session
chilling at the career wherever i go i
make sure i stop and get something
what's crazy is i just got on it like a
year ago
and ever since then i just been hooked
on
i usually don't want to miss it mix it
like i don't want to mess it up like
i got to keep it perfect you feel like
air time with admiral gotta have my
crank great to the side
thanks for watching and thanks for
having me gq these are my essentials to
go out now make sure to go get it
[Music]
okay